c'est parti shas riad ou vérité on y va
première question elle s'adresse à qui
quel est ce que tu en veux à franck
dubosc de t'avoir fait jouer dans all
inclusive à les bâtards est ce que tu
attends du mois avoir fait jouer dans le
musée écoute je n'avais absolument pas
du tout à franck du comment ça s'est
passé en fait ça s'est pas passé via
franck c'est fabien onteniente et
j'adore les acteurs du film qui est un
mec que j'apprécie beaucoup aussi qui
m'a appelé et m'a dit aux fins fumel
franc qui s'appelle une cuisine est ce
que tu veux faire une petite scène à la
fin revient avec plaisir je vais faire
une petite scène à la fin tu as tout
envoi frank j en veux pas du tout
affront qu'il était la vérité maintenant
il est pour rien c'est pas lui qui m'a
appelé mais comme j'étais ravi de venir
je tournais avec franck
oui mais quand même quoi temps tu dors
veut moi je crois que massey n'était pas
essentielle est un film ça s'appelle
vérité je trouve que ma ce n était pas
essence émettait un cachet ce que tu
crois que le film était sans doute trop
de fruits le film et elle avait débord y
avait des montres il y avait eu un
détournement et puis moi c'est avec un
cycle de nous on aime à examiner tout
n'était pas ajouté
c'est comme dans cette émission c'est au
delà de fair play il faut pas en maître
sur les autres la faute j'ai accepté
j'assume
et voilà il a été bien comprendre les
règles si j'avais buzz et qu'est ce qui
se passe rien dossier qui partent on est
passé
si ce soir tu devais choisir une
personne avec qui couché avec qui te
marier et qui tu es ce serait qui ce
soir clara si tu devais choisir avec qui
tu couches avec qui tu te maries etc et
uccle admettant que chevarie ou couché
ce serait avec camilla me marier je suis
désolé a touché toutes les lesbiennes ce
serait avec delphine j'avoue que ça met
à l'homme
non mais non mais à la baisse aurait été
qu'est venu maintenant on est réconcilié
donc quand tu te dis que tu que tu
puisses qui
gilles diss franck dubosc ta maman
séduction alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ce dos en fait se rencontrer déjà
rencontrés il ya de cela quelques bonnes
années s'était invité dans une émission
à ma sortie d'une autre émission j'ai
fait la star academy en france j'avais
17 ans c'est ça la méthode cauet échos
et me faire un compliment et je dis à
quoi il faut surtout remercier ma maman
et mon papa est là dessus franck tu as
dit et maman elle est pas en coulisses
tu me regardes et tu m'as charrier là
dessus tout le restant de les laisser en
coulisses ou pas elle n'était pas en
crise et à l'heureuse mère mais tu m'as
demandé plusieurs fois si elle était la
semaine une photo a changé en blaguant
alors sûrement non maintenant marié
depuis combien de temps fait trente ans
vingt ans après 10 ans non non c'était
avant ses dix ans alors je te parle
charia
voilà on peut le garde pourquoi je
j'aurais cherché la mer alors qu'elle
jouait maintenant 17 ans parce qu'on
parle d'un temps j'étais plus jeune
[Musique]
elle n'est pas célibataire elle est
venue ce soir elle est en coulisses
[Rires]
c'est sympa
baba ici là wav
quelle personnalité n'inviterait tu
jamais dans cette émission n'importe
quelle émission à toi aussi tu vas pas
faire de surprise si la loi
qu'est ce que tu nous diras que tu étais
avec qui étaient avec lui avec qui tu
étais quel droit d'asile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
hewitt avec la base et c'est un dossier
qui est parti sur gad et je trouve c'est
par d'autres se perdent à quel âge as tu
eu 42 je dois voir non moins 12 13 12 12
c'est parti
ryan j'étais en bas de la falaise ce
jour là et je t'en veux regarde
quand tu dois livrer
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
camille dans son dernier single tu
parles de ton ex
est ce que tu peux regarder la caméra
pour lui passer un message c'est que des
succès des tubes alors embrasse très
fort
[Applaudissements]
environ
qui donc a compris que c'était fini
depuis depuis un an 20 jeux ravine en
fait je remercie mon bon je traverse un
moment
[Musique]
je remercie mon axe mon aide je remercie
mon nom
mon nom je remercie mon lait
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore aussi champion du monde
cette finale ici là wav delphine quelle
est la plus grande star quitte à draguer
kevre déjà est-ce que déjà dit la vérité
c'est que ces jeunes qu'elle était déjà
fait draguer oui est ce qu elle déjà les
gens comme cette table
enfin ce soir regardons déjà dragué
avant ce soir
mais la vérité ça on a déjà fait on a
déjà fait un dîner avec franck sait pas
trop mais n'ont pas d'idée ou pas du
tout c'était quelques années on a mangé
ensemble dîner du temps comme ça non
c'était une grande table dîner de
charité au maroc et et et c'était cd
très sympa tabac non sorte à draguer si
c'est donc non personne fine quand tu
vas au maroc appelle moi
[Applaudissements]
maintenant est ce que dit noah chanteur
alors en fait les gars on n'a pas
forcément c'est vrai nom balle
impressionnante et un peu peur en fait
on ne sait pas comment on sait pas trop
comment l'avancé pas comment la bonne
dame non je vais dire que 50 % des
candidats masculins qui viennent un fort
boyard et qui viennent chez blanche
m'écrivent après donc vous donner tout
le casting de toutes les années en
prenant la grande scène en ce sens il
est très sympa et c'est très amicale
meiway 50% des mets des dégâts qui
viennent acheter blanche c'est quoi les
textos en général ouais mais que je
sache pas et voilà c'est très charmante
j'étais impressionné c'est intrigant na
li na na il va progresser et continuer à
les dernières questions et vas-y francky
pour toi qui es le meilleur acteur elie
semoun ou n'importe kg
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
meyer bat de la paix et d'amitié de 30
ans répète de ces tracteurs du coup ça
te coûte arriver ça te coûter au jeu et
coûteux laissez-vous non pas la question
un peu bizarre parce que et lui est un
très très bon acteur il a prouvé maintes
et maintes fois deux ou trois fois mais
en campine
sauf dans valentine annoncer un très bon
acteur maintenant vous qui d'autre non
je trouve que franchement qu'est pour
toi meilleur acteur français au cinéma
par mois paris vincent cassel
extraordinaire non romain duris
marguerite m g on affine émissions et
romain duris il a peu parlé de vos durée
déclarant ces deux nouveaux loud qui
selon toi le corps le plus rigolo sur ce
plateau assez moi c'est moi c'est quoi
encore rigolo accord rigolo photo après
je tenais
[Applaudissements]
g
moi je peux dire c'est très rigolo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ici la web jee c'est quoi ces cas alors
c'est quoi
mais en fait je ne peux même plus
appeler ça des pieds on appelle ça des
samossas combien doritos mais on est
servi cette salle a gagné dernière
d'accord c'est pas mal non
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
toi c'est une explication covan
c'était avant la fermeture des restos
thema vous me dire fermeture des
normales moi jamais ces sétois et bnf
toi montant atteint juste c'est toi
c'est moi c'est toi et toi tu veux des
habits roses bouna sémou oui c'est un
fait qu un régime sans sucre ça on y va
allez jouer sur ce plateau à qui tu taxe
rémy l'euro est acquis donnerais-tu milo
aller si à tout le monde la personne qui
a alors acquis ce texte serait 1000
euros à gad ses chèvres encore la clé tu
donnerais 1000 euros je suis là j'ai ça
peut être très oui parce que tu le
saurais me leroux tout le monde moi non
plus en vrai ça prend de l'argent à
quelqu'un je le fais jamais ce que ça me
stresse redouane c'est quand mes amis
avec ta bientôt strati que j'étais moi
jamais je demanderai wemmel et dan
wheldon qui a besoin de moi je demande
fidh
moi non plus je m'en parle encore alors
ok alors vas-y
enfin il faut demander répond je suis
timide soit sûr est ce une en russe
non mais si toi
[Applaudissements]
la maintenance crête de l'argent à un
ami tu perdras l'argent et l'ami aussi
les traits en galère tu es si les voilà
c'est le traître est en galère du dojo
mieux offrir l'argent un ami que la
terre ce soir-là perdu je vous en ai
changé